am abend wird der faule fleißig wie es
so schön heißt spät erwacht in
deutschland die erkenntnis dass es
sicherheit demokratie und wohlstand
nicht zum nulltarif gibt
zeitenwende nennt es der bundeskanzler
also die bundeswehr muss ertüchtigt
werden die nato dem gewissenlosen
krimmel herrscher die grenzen zeigen
putins krieg wie muss sich deutschland
schützen jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist familie
schäfer ist es den
bundestagsabgeordneten der bündnisgrünen
und mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
des bundestages dort mitglied ist
ebenfalls roderich kiesewetter
allerdings von der cdu csu fraktion und
sind auch für die cdu ob man in diesem
auswärtigen ausschuss und sie sind
ehemaliger oberst der bundeswehr
zugeschaltet sind uns julia schramm
autoren sie sind auch mitglied des
bundesvorstandes der linkspartei und
eine der initiatorinnen des appells von
prominenten aus politik kultur und
wissenschaft die sich gegen die
ausrüstungs pläne die aktuellen
auflistung pläne der regierung richten
und thomas wiegold ist bei uns freier
journalist mit den schwerpunkten
verteidigungs und sicherheitspolitik
bundeswehr und militär sie betreiben den
sicherheitspolitischen blog auch
geradeaus und den podcast
sicherheitshalber thomas wiegold ist
putins angriffskrieg wenn wir jetzt die
neuesten meldungen aus der ukraine hört
ist er schon gescheitert oder sollten
wir uns dann nicht zu früh freuen
also ich glaube da müssen wir noch ein
bisschen vorsichtig sein
überraschend war ja für viele im westen
dass russland mit den streitkräften
nicht so vorangekommen ist wie jeder
sind ja ganz viele davon ausgegangen
innerhalb weniger tage feldkirch und
russland hat das alles unter kontrolle
das hat nicht geklappt ob das aber heißt
die russischen streitkräfte sind so gar
nicht in der lage das es jetzt von der
gegenpol wie man manchmal hört die
modernisierung die wir die vergangenen
jahre dort gesehen haben die waren nur
im wortsinne ein potemkinsches dorf also
da würde ich wirklich sehr vorsichtig
und fragezeichen da machen die kinder
die größte befürchtung hierzulande ist
ja dass putin den krieg in die nato
hineinträgt ist diese gefahr real das
glaube ich nicht aber eine andere gefahr
ist real dass wir weiterhin glauben wenn
dieser krieg rom es bleibt alles beim
alten ich denke dass ganz entscheidend
ist dass nukleare abschreckung wirkt so
bitter es ist und zwar anders als wir
gedacht haben und dass eine legende der
bundesrepublik deutschland vorbei ist
dass wir von freuen nur ein partnern
umgeben sind und uns nur um uns selber
kümmern können der krieg ist leider
zurückgekehrt deshalb brauchen wir eine
andere sicherheitskultur in deutschland
schäfer die bündnisgrünen sind ja in der
bundesregierung und sie tragen auch die
auf und ausrüstung der bundeswehr mit
ist das für eine partei mit
pazifistischen wurzeln ist dass kröten
schlucken oder ist dass die einsicht
dass nichts mehr so ist wie es mal war
also mir ist erst mal ganz wichtig zu
sagen das ist hier nicht um aufrüstung
geht sondern es geht darum dass wir die
bundeswehr anständig ausrüsten und ich
durfte mich jetzt auch in den
vergangenen monaten wo ich mich
eingearbeitet habe im bundestag vermehrt
damit beschäftigung ist ehrlich gesagt
auch als arbeitgeber der bundeswehr
schon peinlich wenn ich höre da fehlen
zum beispiel winterjacken an der
ostflanke ins netz mir ist wichtig dass
wir natürlich bei aldi sind fragen was
wird denn jetzt noch beschafft immer
gucken was steckt tatsächlich die
bündnisfähigkeit so das alles
tatsächlich in der strategie mit unseren
internationalen partnern auch abgestimmt
wird und eben nicht sinnlos geld einfach
verschleudert wird an die
rüstungsindustrie sondern das gebot der
stunde ist dann glaube ich sorgfalt vor
schnelligkeit
ich sagte er auf und ausrüstung julia
schon wird wahrscheinlich eher von
aufrüstung
reden julia schramm die ligna diese
aufrüstung ab mit anderen zusammen als
reaktion auf den angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine reicht es wirklich einen
kriegsverbrecher mit gutem zureden
beschwichtigen zu wollen
also
das ist glaube ich sehr verkürzt jetzt
du hast so darzustellen weil das geht ja
nicht darum dass die nato der
russland unterlegen sein und man sich
jetzt schützen müsste die nato staaten
sind los land militärisch was ich
überlegen und eine hochrüstung von
konventionellen waffen in dieser
situation ändert an dem dilemma nichts
dass die nato jetzt in die handlungs
losigkeit gezwungen wird aufgrund des
unverhohlenen drohung des einsatzes
verklären
wie gold richten wir mal die augen
geradeaus auf die bundeswehr in der tat
was julia schramm gerade angesprochen
hat der haushalt der
verteidigungshaushalt aller nato staaten
ist es nicht höher als der
verteidigungshaushalt russlands aber der
heeresinspekteur sagt neulich die
bundeswehr steht blank da würden sie wie
würden sie denn den zustand der
bundeswehr bezeichnen die sie ja schon
seit langer zeit beobachten
ja in manchen punkten hat alfons preis
sicheres inspekteur durchaus recht die
bundeswehr ist ja den vergangenen 20
jahren etwa 25 jahren umgebaut worden zu
einer armee zu einer streitmacht für
geplante ausland seien über
jahre in afghanistan jetzt brauche ich
darüber reden war das sinnvoll oder
nicht
erst mal nur wenn wir uns die struktur
angucken es ist alles darauf optimiert
worden soldaten und verbände wussten in
einem jahr in zwei jahren manchmal sogar
in drei jahren geht es nach afghanistan
dafür war das material da das wurde
alles organisiert und die vorstellung
die glaube ich auch viele bürger in
unserem land hatten vielleicht immer
noch haben da ist halt die bundeswehr
die sitzt an ihrer kaserne hat ihr gerät
und wenn krieg kommt dann fahren die
irgendwie los das funktioniert ja alles
nicht wir haben eine armee also nicht
nur das her sondern insgesamte
streitkräfte die sind reduziert worden
über die jahre das war politisch so
gewollt das ist ja auch in ordnung das
material ist teilweise noch stärker
reduziert worden es gibt verbände bis
heute die haben 70 prozent der
ausrüstung die sie eigentlich haben
müssten das heißt auf dem papier hat
deutschland eine bundeswehr die viel
mehr kann nach der theoretischen lage
als sie tatsächlich kann und da ist
eigentlich das problem wenn soldaten
dastehen und sagen na ja wir haben zwei
drittel der autos der panzer welches
gerät auch immer dann ist das nichts was
funktioniert aber das ist hingenommen
worden diese wird dass sie waren lange
bundeswehr offizier gewesen
generalstabsoffizier am ende sie kennen
die abläufe in der bundeswehr sehr gut
ist die bundeswehr einfach falsch
ausgestattet ins in die falsche richtung
gerüstet worden ist das jetzt auch ein
dilemma dar einfach von jetzt auf gleich
durch diese bedrohung die ja übrigens
auch nicht so vom himmel gefallen ist
jetzt umzuschwenken ja wir müssen das
ganz nüchtern und auch selbstkritisch
sehen zwischen 1990 und 2000 14 weil die
bundeswehr steinbruch für andere
haushalte wo sicherlich das eine oder
andere mal der verteidigungshaushalt
erhöht wurde aber dann wenn geld
gebraucht wurde wurde es in andere
bereiche umgeschichtet eklatant war 2011
die acht milliarden eingespart wurden
und 2011 auch der libyen-krieg seitdem
sind die munitions bestände der
bundeswehr nicht mehr aufgefüllt worden
aber es war eben eine andere
sicherheitskultur die bundeswehr war
nicht wesentlich weder bei einer
regierung helmut kohl noch bei einer
regierung schröder noch bei einer
regierung merkel es war einfach sie war
da sie hat die auslandseinsätze
hervorragend geleistet mit großen opfern
vielen traumatisierten aber auch vielen
opfern und verwundeten aber für die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung haben
wir erst erkannt mit dem krimkrieg 2014
ost ukraine dass wir die bundeswehr neu
auswahl so acht ja also vor acht jahren
oder dauerstreit waren verteidigung ist
der ausschließlich aus ihrer partei ist
schon seit 2005 bis jetzt für platin und
bis zum regierungswechsel
wir hatten auch ein koalitionspartner
der dass zwei prozent ziel nicht
umsetzen wollte wohl steinmeiers
unterschrieben hat und das gehört auch
zur ehrlichkeit dazu das thema
bewaffnete drohnen oder tornado
nachfolge ist in der letzten periode
verschleppt worden und da wir
koalitionstreu sind möchte hier auch
nicht den koalitionspartner kritisieren
sondern loben dass die jetzige
bundesregierung den schwenk endlich
vollzogen hat der uns viele jahre lang
nicht gelungen ist sind das als erblast
an was an verteidigung
sicherheitspolitik geleistet worden ist
in den 16 jahren der ära merkel ja also
was wir ja schon sehen dass klagen ja
jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen durch
wir haben natürlich schon einen sehr
großen wert aber sind trotzdem als armee
also sogar den siebtgrößten der welt
aber sind trotzdem nicht wirklich gut
einsatzfähig und da sehen wir natürlich
schon dass auch im beschaffungswesen
einiges falsch gelaufen sein muss weil
sonst würde sich dieses bild ja auch gar
nicht ergeben und da müssen jetzt
natürlich auch noch mal nicht nur gucken
dass wir noch mehr geld auf so ein
ineffizientes system schützen sondern
eben auch ganz genau beim controlling
ansetzen und schauen dass wirklich die
ausgaben war sinnvoller getätigt werden
und sich mehr an den bedürfnissen der
soldaten und daten orientieren und eine
unserer bündnisfähigkeit als an
irgendwelchen lobbyinteressen was
vermutlich eines der probleme ist das
wir lösen müssen ich sehe aber noch was
als schwierigkeit an wo wir jetzt als
neue bundesregierung natürlich einiges
zu tun haben was in der vergangenheit
verschlafen wurde nämlich die große
abhängigkeit zum beispiel von russischem
erdöl gas und kohle da müssen jetzt das
ruder um 180 grad rumreißen und ich
glaube auch dieses ganze thema energie
souveränität auch als teilaspekt von
sicherheitspolitik wurde zum beispiel
viel zu wenig erkannt es gibt noch viele
andere bereiche wie der zivilschutz
beispielsweise den wir uns auch stärker
an gucken müssen cyber abwehr haben
jetzt schon riesige to-do-liste aber wir
wollen natürlich alles notwendige tun
wir werden das mit der cyber abwehr und
auch mit der frage
energiepolitik wie das zusammenhängt
noch ansprechen in der sendung ich würde
gerne einen anderen kleinen kurzen zeit
geht machen wir jetzt ursächlich mit der
ukraine mit dem uke krieg nichts zu tun
hat aber wenn man die bundeswehr
tüchtigen will geht es ja nicht nur das
material sondern auch um die soldaten um
die um die personalstruktur es gibt auch
immer wieder ärger mit extremismus
verdacht in den gruppen teilen gerade in
einem ganz wichtigen truppenteil der
eigentlich für die bekämpfung für die
verteidigung des landes auch sehr
wichtig ist sind von 183.000 soldaten
geht es um knapp 600 das ist nicht sehr
viel aber es gibt diese fälle in wie wir
irgendwie fern schadet dieses schaden
diese vorgänge der bundeswehr aus der
jetzt auch in der hinsicht dass man ja
tatsächlich sehr viel ändern muss die
schaden natürlich enorm also sie haben
es angesprochen es ist natürlich es gibt
einen großen anteil an soldaten und
soldaten denen wir einfach sehr große
dankbarkeit schuldig sind für ihren
tagtäglichen einsatz ich glaube auch
dass diese dankbarkeit in der
vergangenheit oft zu kurz gekommen ist
und vielleicht auch die anreize dann zur
armee zu gehen nicht groß genug waren um
eben auch ja genügend rekrutierung und
gutes personal leben hilfe bekommen und
deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt eben
gerade die schwarzen schafe genau
angucken brauchen da eine null toleranz
strategie wenn wir natürlich nicht
riskieren können dass die
einsatzfähigkeit darunter leidet und
eben auch eine gefahr ausgeht von diesen
personen weil man stellt sich dass vor
jeder rechtsextremist beispielsweise der
eine waffe hat ist natürlich eine
riesige gefahr für unsere innere
sicherheit und nicht nur für das image
der bundeswehr ich teile das was frau
schäfer sagt insbesondere weil wir in
den letzten jahren die militärischen
abschirmdienst vom kopf auf die füße
gestellt haben und der militärische
abschirmdienst endlich nicht nur schaut
dass diese leute die bundeswehr
verlassen sondern auch dafür sorgt dass
sie dem verfassungsschutz übergeben
werden das halte ich für ganz wesentlich
und das ist in den letzten zwei jahren
geschehen und es ist wirklich gut weil
das auch das vertrauen in die bundeswehr
verbessert und da die afg als
verdachtsfall jetzt eingestuft ist macht
es auch generell einfacher in den
streitkräften rechtsextremismus zu
bekämpfen ich warne aber davor wir
müssen auch meinen islamistischen
extremismus denken gut das war der grund
war jetzt die bundeswehr braucht
vertrauen das sagen sie und das gehört
jetzt sehr viel mit dem zu tun worüber
wir eigentlich reden frau schreiben sie
haben gerade ja auch schon gesagt warum
sie aufrüstung
rüstungskäufe ablehnen glauben sie denn
wenn man sich jetzt die bilder aus der
ukraine ansieht und diese aggressive
politik von putin der im wahrsten sinn
des wortes über leichen geht dass man
überhaupt nicht sich auf oder dass man
zumindest das in gewisser weise oder an
bestimmten stellen sich rüsten muss um
putin auch abzuschrecken und zu sagen
also finger weg von uns und vor allen
dingen verschwindet er aus der ukraine
ich glaube abgeschreckt ist nicht die
notwendigkeit also es hat elisabeth
gerade selber gesagt die nukleare
abschreckung scheint zu funktionieren
was ich aber nochmal jetzt anschließend
daran sagen möchte also es wirkt auf
mich so dass die bundeswehr eine
ausgetrocknete pflanze ist auf die man
jetzt 100 milliarden liter wasser kippt
mit der hoffnung dass sie am nächsten
tag blüht ich glaube das ist der falsche
ansatz weil die strukturellen probleme
die vorhanden sind wir können ja nicht
innerhalb verschwinden ja nicht über
nacht was man kann die 100 milliarden
über nacht beschließen aber man kann
nicht über nacht hat die
strukturprobleme
lösen und ich meine die bundeswehr hat
einen grundgesetzlichen auftrag der
landesverteidigung dem scheint sie nicht
nachkommen zu können und den scheint sie
auch schon lange nicht nachkommen zu
können und ich würde gerne erstmal das
alles geklärt haben bevor und das sehen
wir haben nicht nur rechte sondern auch
sehr viele andere
bevor da 100 milliarden sondervermögen
im grundgesetz verankert wird
in einer hauruck aktion
bei gleichzeitiger beibehaltung der
schulden was de facto bedeutet dass wir
eine mehr militär haben weiß auch muss
man sagen gesellschaftliche auswirkungen
hat und gleichzeitig die gefahr mehr
abend das muss ich ehrlich sagen ist das
rezept ob bei dem putin diesen angriff
street überhaupt führen konnte weil
deshalb haben wir als gesellschaft und
auch als legt so selbstkritisch muss
sich unwillig sein da das haben wir
nicht erst suchen und wir haben nicht
laut genug kritisiert was in russland in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten auch an
militarisierung stattgefunden hat und
ich glaube daraus müssen wir auch lernen
und das bedeutet eben auch dass wir wenn
wir die bundeswehr
aufrüsten wie es immer so schön heißt
dass es in einem demokratisch kontext
statt mit in einer demokratischen
debatten das ist dass es 40.000 menschen
mit diesem appell fordern und ich finde
dass es geboten und es notwendig frau
haben wenn sie wie sie sagen gerade wir
brauchen jetzt erstmal zeit eine
bestandsaufnahme zu machen was wir mit
dieser ausgetrockneten pflanze machen
aber zeit ist ja gerade etwas was sie im
moment kaum haben weil wir haben es gibt
eine massive bedrohung aus dem osten
zunächst mal nicht nur für die ukraine
da hat es ja schon stattgefunden sondern
eben auch für die ostflanke der nato
also die ostflanke in der nato aufgeben
aber durch die nato weiterhin geschützt
das problem ist doch gerade und er muss
ich ehrlich sagen bin ich auch wenn man
da seiner linken vielleicht nicht aus
much unterstellen würde aber noch
durchaus dankbar dass dieser nuklearer
eskalation bisher auch von nato seite
massiv versucht wurde zu verhindern das
müssen wir auch mal festhalten
die dachrinnen die jetzt von diesen 100
millionen sondervermögen gekauft werden
die tornado nachfolger beispielsweise
das sind alles dinge die stehen schon im
koalitionsvertrag drin das heißt also
dass es auch eine kritik die ich noch
viele andere haben da ist sozusagen
dieser furchtbaren bilder aus mario pohl
und so weiter und so fort jetzt auch
benutzt werden um projekte
durchzubringen die im koalitionsvertrag
schon drin die tornado nachfolger
beispielsweise und das finde ich auch
problematisch ich glaube dass das nicht
der richtige weg ist ist das für uns als
gesellschaft nicht der richtige weg ist
dass diese zeitenwende dann aber nur
beim militär stattfindet weil das was
auch die spanier schon gesagt hat wir
müssen auch massiv in erneuerbare
energien investieren da waren auch
bisher auch die grünen in den ländern
nicht so engagiert und wir müssen dann
auch massiv uns unabhängig machen von
geben
energieimporten weil war sehr zäh ist
dass wir katar und auch bis zum gewissen
grad saudi arabien uns dort in die
appelle sind und wie die kriege medien
also wir haben sozusagen eine ganze
stelle und das thema soziale
gerechtigkeit was natürlich wahnsinnig
wichtig ist auch nicht als linke das
haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen weil
es ist natürlich für die menschen
absolut unverständlich wie über nacht
100 milliarden zur verfügung stehe man
für pflege bonus von 1,5 milliarden zwei
jahre kämpfen ist gut wir werden das
werden wir ich würde eher die frage ganz
kurz thomas wiegold die energiefrage und
auch die frage sozialer gerechtigkeit
werde ich nachher nochmal kurz auch mit
mit erwähnen erst vor schäfer und dann
thomas wiegold ja ich möchte julia
schreiben gerne in vielen punkten recht
geben weil ich halte es auch für falsch
wenn wir jetzt einfach die 100
milliarden in einem sehr kurzen zeitraum
einfach so raus hauen weil dann erfüllt
sich genau dass das eben wieder die
shopping liste der rüstungsindustrie
abgearbeitet wird und eben gar nichts
getan wird für die sicherheit und viele
andere prioritäten eben hinten
runterfallen das darf ihm nicht
passieren deswegen es ist jetzt gut dass
wir festgelegt haben dass diese 100
milliarden so sie denn so beschlossen
werden sollten eben auch in einem
unbegrenzten zeitraum zur verfügung
stehen und ein an ein hartes controlling
auch
gekoppelt sind und ich glaube es muss
auch der anspruch sein dass eben bevor
wir gelder in aus diesem sondervermögen
ausgeben das beschaffungswesen jetzt mit
hochdruck reformiert wird die vorschläge
dazu liegen auch teilweise schon in der
schublade die müssen wir jetzt einfach
mutig umsetzen und ich will noch was du
der fall so schwierigen
prioritätensetzung sagen die auch julia
schreiben schon angesprochen hat ich
teile das auch das natürlich dieser
eindruck der bei der bevölkerung
entstehen kann für alle anderen
gesellschaftlichen bereiche gilt die
schuldenbremse aber für das andere
nämlich die militärische ausrüstung ist
jetzt eben das geld da deshalb glaube
ich auch es geht darum gerade den
sozialen zusammenhalt und eben den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien jetzt
genauso im blick zu haben und eben auch
ganz klar zu sagen es möchte ich auch an
der stelle tun auch wenn es unser
finanzminister in der regierung anders
sieht wir können jetzt gar nicht seriös
sagen dass wir die schuldenbremse
angesichts dieser großen
herausforderungen haben schön dass für
sondervermögen bundeswehr das ist ja die
idee der ampel koalition ist gezielt aus
dem haushalt herausgenommen worden und
unternehmer ja gar nicht der
schuldenbremse thomas wiegold
ja ich bin kein politiker deswegen kann
ich auch einfach mal versuchen noch paar
fakten in die debatte zu werfen also zum
einen der punkt mit der militarisierung
die frau schreiben gerade angesprochen
hat es wird ja durch in diese
zusätzlichen finanziellen mittel keinen
einzigen zusätzlichen soldaten geben die
bundeswehr hat seit jahren den plan auf
zwei rund 200.000 soldaten aufzuwachsen
das funktioniert bislang nicht das hat
aber eher mit personalgewinnung mit der
nachwuchswerbung zu tun dass es nicht
eine frage des geldes also und die 100
milliarden bedeuten nicht es wird auf
einmal neue schimmernde wer und es
ziehen überall viel mehr soldaten durch
die städte der andere punkt ist die 100
milliarden werden nicht wie der
frühlingsregen über der bundeswehr
ausgegossen und versickern dann nächste
woche oder nächstes jahr sondern werden
das wurde ja auch schon erwähnt
langfristig dazu dienen die
investitionen in größere projekte
abzusichern
der punkt ist einfach eine beschaffung
und es sind ja nicht nur die tornados
sind hubschrauber da die
1972 ihren erstflug in der bundeswehr
hatten also diese
ersatzbeschaffung die zieht sich über
jahre hin wenn man heute bestellt kommt
der erste hubschrauber in zwei drei
jahren und der letzte einer serie
vielleicht den sieben acht oder zehn
jahren und die ganze haushalt systematik
das wird herr kiesewetter vielleicht
auch aus leidvoller erfahrung wissen ist
ja so dass eigentlich immer nur für das
folgende jahr der haushalt
festgemacht werden kann und dass die
langfristige finanzierung von solchen
projekten nicht gesichert ist das ist
der eigentliche sinn dieser 100
milliarden nicht auf einmal die
badewanne auskippen über der bundeswehr
dann noch ein weiterer punkt drin
ausgeliefert wird er nicht
vielleicht doch genau den punkt so
streicht auch mal einen punkt wozu dann
diese änderung im grundgesetz die
nächste woche schon im boden des rats
entsteht damit damit ist also ist es
jetzt über jahre
also irgendwann muss man sich
entscheiden
sie müssen sich entscheiden ob sie im
grundgesetz etwas langfristig
abgesichert haben wollen oder ob sie
sagen eine langfristige absicherung im
grundgesetz kompletten stellt das ding
ist kurzfristig also irgendwie verstehe
ich ihre argumentation an der stelle
nicht
mehr die argumentation es
geht aus dem 100 milliarden die sie in
einer diskussion auch im bundestag jetzt
geht auch braucht man ja auch die union
wenn man es als besonderen gesetze
formuliert weil es eine
grundgesetzänderung da stellt eine
ergänzung des artikels 57a
angenommen das sie nun 80 jahre lasse
ich mich gerne korrigieren also artikel
87a und man braucht nur zwei drittel
mehrheit also die union dazu diese es
war ja jetzt hier die kritik die man
immer wieder hört am beschaffungswesen
der bundeswehr da schon die ein
regelrechtes jammertal zu sein seit
vielen jahrzehnten allerdings kann man
ja mit diesem geld jetzt auch
rüstungsgüter kaufen die schon auf dem
markt sind tarnkappen bomber sollen
gekauft wenn 35 stück möglicherweise
auch ein luftabwehrsystem namen namens
error free dass die israelis mit den
amerikanern entwickelt haben das auf dem
markt ist das sehr wirksam ist und dass
möglicherweise gekauft werden kann dann
kann man dieses beschaffungswesen ja um
schießen diese 100 milliarden die man
dafür jetzt im bundestag bzw die
bundesregierung hat ist ja jetzt
zunächst mal als kabinettsbeschluss
erlassen die 100 milliarden die man
jetzt in die hand reichen überhaupt aus
der kehler das ist ja genau der punkt
und ich bin da ganz bei frau schäfer
aber auch was her wie gold sagte und ich
glaube die frau hat's ja irgendwo auch
angedeutet es geht jetzt nicht darum so
schnell wie möglich die 100 milliarden
unterzubringen deswegen wird das als
sondervermögen deklariert und dann über
mehrere jahre verteilt und es klingt ja
an entscheidend ist das eine dass wir an
dass zwei prozent ziel kommen vorsicht
vor den zahlen besser ist dass wir
standardisierung erreichen in der
bessere fähigkeit zur zusammenarbeit
denn wenn das bruttoinlandsprodukt sinkt
dann sind auch die zwei prozent weniger
und das andere ist die hälfte der 100
milliarden können wir sehr rasch
ausgeben 30 milliarden werden die
munitions bestände ausmachen die die
bundeswehr auffüllen muss seit dem
libyen-krieg 2011 dann haben wir die
tornado nachfolge sie haben es
angesprochen die bewaffneten drohnen die
in der alten koalition vom
koalitionspartner blockiert wurden und
jetzt kommen sollen der schwere
transporthubschrauber und etliches mehr
dann sind wir schon bei 50 milliarden
die sie zu beschaffen dauert auch seine
zeit aber das sind markt verfügbare
güter das ist innerhalb von 34 jahren zu
leisten die andere hälfte die
bundesregierung hat gesagt sie möchte
eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie das
begrüßen wir die andere sollten wir ganz
eng an die nationale
sicherheitsstrategie anschließen und
prüfen was sind unsere außenpolitischen
interessen sicherheitspolitischen
interessen was sind unsere prioritäten
was wollen wir mit der bundeswehr aber
auch im bereich katastrophenschutz
zivilschutz erreichen und dann
priorisiert die mittel verwenden also
nicht mit der gießkanne und das ist auch
eine botschaft an unsere bevölkerung
dass hier sehr sorgsam mit diesem
sondervermögen umgegangen werden muss
und deswegen ist ja auch der bundestag
beteiligt und das ist zu begrüßen dass
die unionsfraktion da offensichtlich
mitwirken darf und wir wollen auch
mitwirken aber dann geht es eben uns
darum nicht mit der gießkanne herum zu
darf ich noch mal was nachfragen 100
milliarden hieß es ja für die stärkung
der verteidigungs- und der
bündnisfähigkeit
der streitkräfte ist das ursprünglich
dann soll so hört man aus
koalitionskreisen die grünen darauf
gedrungen haben diese zwei worte der
streitkräfte zu streichen damit also
auch klar ist dass möglicherweise teile
der 100 milliarden sie haben es vorhin
schon angedeutet eben nicht für die
rüstungsbeschaffung da sind sondern für
anderes was im umfeld der
sicherheitspolitik wichtig ist gehen sie
damit es muss für die bundeswehr seien
aber bundeswehr ist auch
territorialverteidigung
territorialverteidigung ist auch
heimatschutz bevölkerungsschutz und das
sind schon bereiche über die wir
sprechen sollten das bundesamt für
katastrophenhilfe und bevölkerungsschutz
hat 100 millionen euro beantragt im
bundeshaushalt und bekommt nur 24
millionen zugewiesen das ist das am 2
die sirenen nicht funktionieren dürfen
das amt möchte aber dass die sirenen
funktionieren und wir müssen auch über
reserve und auch zivile reserve
nachdenken gesellschaft
unterstützungskräfte an breiten
freiwilligendienst hoffentlich oder ein
pflichtdienst aber der auf alle fälle in
die richtung geht weg wie verbessern die
die unterstützungs fähigkeit unserer
gesellschaft aber die 100 milliarden
sind vorrangig für die bundeswehr diese
100 milliarden wie gesagt weil es eine
grundgesetzänderung in einem
sondervermögen bedeutet kann nicht ohne
und zustimmung der union als zwei
drittel mehrheit durch den bundestag
gehen im moment scheint aber diese
einigkeit und dieses einvernehmen
zwischen der ampel koalition und der
unionsfraktion zu wackeln denn sie haben
da offensichtlich noch ganz
unterschiedliche auffassungen also wir
sind uns hier sehr einig weil herr
kiesewetter hat schon einen sehr
wichtigen punkt angesprochen wir können
nicht nur sozusagen die feindes abwehr
durch zum beispiel
raketenabwehrsysteme diskutiert ohne den
bevölkerungsschutz weil natürlich im
notfall ist es auch wichtig dass wir
unsere bevölkerung mit ausreichend
trinkwasser vorräten beispielsweise oder
medikamenten versorgen können und da
sind wir momentan nicht so gut
aufgestellt wie wir sein müssten dass es
der eine punkt und dann gibt es
natürlich auch bei der cyber abwehr zum
beispiel der zusammenarbeit zwischen bmi
und dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium die ja
auch sozusagen häuser übergreifend
möglich ist wo zum beispiel auch die
bundeswehr auf die cyber
sicherheitsstrukturen des
bundesinnenministeriums zugreifen kann
und deshalb war es uns eben wichtig
diesen passus auch noch mal ein bisschen
zu erweitern weil es eben bei dem
sicherheits begriff den wir für moderne
und auch für richtig halten um mehr geht
wichtig ist dass wir nichts machen was
an der nato vorbeigeht keinen alleingang
die nord stream 1 oder nord stream 2 und
auch bei der luftverteidigung die ja
geplant ist das muss in die nato
integriert werden so dass unsere partner
auch sehen wir übernehmen verantwortung
lastenteilung transatlantisch aber auch
für osteuropa keinen nationalen
sonderweg thomas wieder und lassen sie
uns einmal ein projekt herauspicken was
die luftabwehr maßnahmen angeht das
sieht man ja auch im ukraine krieg wie
wichtig das ist es geht um ein luft
raketen abwehrsystem dass man
offensichtlich ja nicht von deutschland
aus betreiben aber auch über nato länder
östlich von deutschland spannen kann
arrows rhi genannt also ein ein
raketenabwehrsystem gegen mittel- und
langstrecken waffen das relativ gut
funktioniert vielleicht können sie kurz
erklären was das ist wie das
funktioniert und welchen sinn es macht
das möglicherweise jetzt auf und diesen
100 milliarden euro zu kaufen
bei der letzten frage sag ich weiß ich
noch nicht es geht einfach darum es gibt
verschiedene ebenen der luftverteidigung
in deutschland die bundeswehr hat diese
patriot flugabwehrsysteme die also im
wesentlichen
kurzstreckenraketen abwehren können und
flugzeuge die werden jetzt zum beispiel
auch teilweise in die slowakei verlegt
an die ostgrenze des bündnisses um da
sozusagen diesen schutzschirm
aufzuspannen was jetzt im gespräch ist
ein system das
mittelstreckenraketen und
langstreckenraketen abwehren kann
da ist immer noch die frage und das ist
ein bisschen jetzt hoch gehängt worden
in den vergangenen tagen dieses
israelische system es gibt auch ein
amerikanisches system fed heißt es was
so ähnlich arbeitet also da ist man im
grunde genommen genommen in einer markt
sichtung zu sagen wir müssen mehr haben
wir müssen sozusagen noch mehr
schutzschirm aufspannen können
allerdings und das gehört zur
ehrlichkeit dazu
eine hundertprozentige sicherheit mit
einem solchen schutzschirm die gibt es
nicht selbst die israelis die ja viel
erfahrung haben die ein relativ kleines
territorium absichern müssen kriegen
keine hundertprozentige käseglocke hin
das ist ja nicht wie bei star wars wo
die schutzschilder ausgefahren werden
und dann kommt nichts mehr durch sondern
es ist sind abfangraketen mit einer
gewissen trefferwahrscheinlichkeit und
trefferwahrscheinlichkeit heißt es
bleibt bleiben auch welche über die
durchkommen das gilt erst recht für neue
hyperschall waffen die russland
teilweise hat teilweise neu entwickelt
die usa auch also nur auf einen solchen
schutzschirm zu setzen das wäre glaube
ich ein gefährlicher irrtum das wird
sein müssen das haben wir in der ukraine
gesehen aber nur um ein praktisches
beispiel zu nehmen es gab diesen
russischen luftangriffs schon relativ
früh im krieg auch dieses
ausbildungszentrum bei lemberg im westen
der ukraine eigentlich ein militärisch
nicht besonders bedeutendes ziel aber
die russen haben darauf mehr als 30
marschflugkörper abgeschossen wenn man
nun weiß dass so eine patriot batterie
wie die bundeswehr sich auch hat eine
batterie
gleichzeitig fünf ziele bekämpfen kann
also maximal fünf dieser mars flug gab
mal ins visier nehmen kann dann hat man
eine idee welchen aufwand betreiben muss
wenn der gegner kommt und einfach eine
hinreichend große zahl von
marschflugkörpern von raketen in die
richtung wo man steht abfeuert das muss
man alles im auge behalten auch an den
summen die da wahrscheinlich
aufgerufen werden die zwei milliarden
die genannt wurden für einen
schutzschirm über deutschland das halte
ich für sehr utopisch das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wenn man die preise
könnte kiesewetter nic also da müssen
wir realistisch bleiben gucken was ist
sinnvoll ist muss mehr getan werden als
jetzt aber es ist ja nicht so als könnte
man vollständige sicherheit an dieser
stelle erreicht jetzt ist die frage
wirklich
hundertprozentige sicherheit das glaubt
jeder dass es die nicht geben kann aber
trotzdem muss ja eine sicherheitsgefühl
entstehen das ist ja auch der sinn zu
sagen die bundeswehr muss modernisiert
die muss ertüchtigt werden für diese
gefahr die jetzt richtig droht von osten
her
was was muss da eigentlich zusammen
gespielt was muss da zusammen spielen
gegen uns diese kombination aus seen aus
einer effektiven raketenabwehr und
anderen komponenten und kann die
bundeswehr sind absehbarer zeit auch im
nato kontext überhaupt leisten also ganz
klar das geht nur im bündnis weil es
erstens sehr teuer ist und zweitens dass
die bundesrepublik nicht alleine machen
kann für erhob das radar reicht über
2000 kilometer die raketen auch das
heißt also wenn man so etwas macht dann
natürlich mit den mittel und
osteuropäischen staaten zusammen das
zweite ist bevor man jetzt schnell käufe
getätigt erst einmal marktbeobachtungen
es wurde schon gesagt aber eben auch auf
was für eine bedrohung müssen wir uns
denn einstellen und das sind zum einen
mittelstreckenraketen aus also die ss 26
sind raketen bis 500 kilometer es sind
aber auch raketen wie skandal wo der
vertragsbruch war mit den mittelstrecken
abrüstungsvertrag die reichen bis etwa
1000 kilometer
und dann gibt es weitere raketen die in
der neuen entwicklung sind und da muss
man sehr genau schauen dass man nicht
das falsche system auswählt also wir
müssen wissen welche bedrohung kommt und
schauen was ist markt verfügbar worum es
mir selber entwicklung das zweite ist da
kann deutschland ein ganz großartigen
beitrag als anlehnung partner oder als
rahmen nationen leisten dass wir das mit
den weniger finanzstarken
osteuropäischen staaten und den
baltischen staaten machen und gemeinsam
das organisieren als nato beitrag
deswegen greift es auch ein bisschen
kurz wenn man sagt wir brauchen das
jetzt für deutschland wir brauchen das
für die nato und der dritte aspekt ist
es muss einfach abgestimmt sein im
bündnis und ich sehe es auch als beitrag
zur lastenteilung mit amerika weil wir
europäer dann was übernehmen und noch
ein gedanke unserer rüstungsindustrie
ist ja viel zu sehr auf den nahen und
mittleren osten außerhalb israels
fixiert ich wünschte mir dass das auch
ein projekt ist wo wir auch vermittelbar
für unsere bevölkerung und auch für
bestimmte gruppen die den aufruf
unterschrieben haben hinter dem frau
schramm steht vermittelbar ist wenn wir
unseren eigenschutz verbessern und
unsere rüstungsindustrie in den
europäischen nachbarschaft steht
eingebunden wird das hielte ich für
sinnvoll deswegen ist auch gut dass die
bundesregierung jetzt exportgenehmigung
in die ukraine unterzeichnet hat und
nicht nur exportgenehmigungen nach
ägypten unter zeugt dann nehme ich das
jetzt mal auf frau schwamm was jetzt
herr kiesewetter gerade sagte man muss
die ukraine ja unterstützen will sie
unterstützen
man kann dort nicht militärisch
eingreifen das würde wahrscheinlich das
bedeuten was die meisten fürchten so
eine art dritter weltkrieg oder
jedenfalls eine ausweitung dahin wie
stehen sie denn zu waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine von defensivwaffen es ist ja
jetzt heute bekannt geworden dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland
offensichtlich weitere waffen dorthin
liefern will panzerfäuste drohnen
nachtsichtgeräte also defensivwaffen zur
unterstützung des abwehrkampfes finden
sie das gut dass da waffen dann eine
rolle spielen um einen aggressor wieder
aus dem land zu werfen
jetzt ist natürlich nicht gut dass
waffen eine rolle spielen ich glaube das
teilt auch jeder ich glaube dass die
frage muss sinn machen ist keine waffen
zu liefern putins entscheidungen
die linke ist natürlich gegen
waffenlieferungen und sie ist auch gegen
waffenlieferungen in krisengebiete
ich weiß dass es keine sonderlich
populäre position aber das ist doch
wahnsinnig schwierig der standzuhalten
so fordern sozusagen mit dem aggressor
putins und so weiter ich glaube aber
dass waffen auf dauer keinen frieden
schaffen und ich möchte auch ein satz zu
sagen also die linke hat immer gefordert
dass man ein sicherheits bündnis unter
einschluss von russland
etabliert ich habe letztes jahr im
wahlkampf noch gedacht lass das aber
antiquiert jetzt denke ich die
möglichkeit zu einem bundes aufzubauen
ist so weit weg wie wahrscheinlich nie
aber bei hätten wir dieses bündnis vor
15 jahren versucht zu etablieren dann
hätte man vielleicht diesen krieg
verändern können also ich glaube wir
müssen aus dieser logik das meine ich
übrigens mit militarisierung herbold
genau das passiert auch kiesewetter sagt
denn davon spricht dass man jetzt die
rüstungsindustrie irgendwie mehr
einbinden muss und da vielleicht noch
stolz darauf sein muss es nach die bild
zeitung ja auch schon
betitelt mit unsere waffen benutzt trick
das meint militarisierung das meine ich
mit meinen gesellschaftlichen wechseln
und ich glaube wir müssen uns am ende
des tages geht es nur über verhandlungen
am ende des tages geht es nur über
diplomatie ich bin froh dass da wieder
ein chance beim streift der hoffnung im
rückstand ist weil um ich wage zu
erinnern als ich christlich oder
produzenten zusammen das zitat aber
johnson übermittelt von einem veteranen
des ersten weltkriegs ist ja gesagt hat
nach jahren des kämpfens haben sich die
starken führer an einen tisch gesetzt
und diplomatische lösung hätten sie das
früher gemacht wäre eine ganze menge
blut nicht vergessen gut jetzt die frage
und der erste weltkrieg vergleichbar ist
und mit ihr und ihren gerade ist auch in
dieser runde ist mir schon klar aber ich
bin auch viele andere gemeinde ist gut
sie können ja gerne her da ihre ansicht
äußern wenn sie jetzt sagen dass mit der
verständigung mit russland das ist
allerdings die nato russland akte das
ist vergossene milch was sie jetzt zu
den waffenlieferungen gesagt haben sehen
die menschen die im moment in mariupol
ausharren möglicherweise anders es geht
ja darum um einen aggressor aus dem land
zu werfen und mit guten worten werden
sie das nicht schaffen können
ich muss ins tatsächlich sagen man sieht
aber auch das ist nur mit militärischen
geschützt ja auch nicht reicht also wird
das hat er die leute am anfang gesagt
diese übermacht diese russische stand im
raum und was passiert die menschen in
extreme bekämpfen russische panzer mit
traktoren also es ist da geht es doch
auch um viel mehr das zeigt doch dass es
auch im free viel mehr geht als um eine
militärische dominanz die nato hat und
um einen militärischen sieg wir reden
hier von werken unseren grundsätzen
und die müssen dann aber auch ausgefüllt
werden und wir dürfen noch jetzt nicht
in so einem krieg einfach auf die
militärische logik setzen und damit auch
unsere eigenen werte und grundsätze
gleich mit in die tonne werfen wir
dürfen in seinem krieg nicht genau so
werden wie putin ist das ist meine feste
überzeugung und ich glaube aber dass
waffen keinen wissenschaften
ganz kurz nur was mich so bewegt sie
sprechen von militärischer logik frau
schwamm was mich so bewegt ist das 1994
die ukraine drittstärkste nuklearmacht
der welt war auch aus kostengründen aber
auch aus friedens gründen bewusst darauf
verzichtet hat die nuklearwaffen an den
rechtsnachfolger der sowjetunion
russland übergeben hat nukleare
abrüstung gemacht hat dafür einen
friedensvertrag einen vertrag besser
gesagt mit garantien bekommen hat das
budapester memorandum das 2014 gebrochen
ist und 2008 wie 2014 wollte die ukraine
einen nato-beitritt plan haben und
deutschland und frankreich haben dass
beide male verhindert um russland nicht
zu provozieren um keine eskalation zu
machen und dieses land das auf
nuklearwaffen verzichtet hat steht jetzt
vor unserer haustür vor dem
zusammenbruch wir werden nie mehr ein
land wie iran oder nordkorea nach diesem
krieg überzeugende claire abzurüsten das
ist eine ganz bittere erkenntnis die
noch nicht weit in der gesellschaft
verbreitet ist aber mich bewegt so wenn
sie von militärischer logik sprechen
dass die ukraine auf militärische logik
seinerzeit verzichtete auf die logik des
kalten krieges mit nuklearwaffen sich zu
schützen und jetzt daran zerbricht das
finde ich nicht wieder gut zu machen
werde ich vielleicht noch kurz ergänzen
dürfte ich habe mir vor ein paar wochen
beziehungsweise monaten aber nicht
vorstellen können dass ich mal es
richtig finde waffen in ein kriegsgebiet
zu liefern aber ich finde es in dieser
situation absolut richtig weil wir doch
sehen dass die ukraine und vor allem die
menschen in der ukraine
bereit sind dafür zu kämpfen eben nicht
von putin
einfach einverleibt zu werden und dann
eben wieder teil eines eines autoritären
staates zu sein die wollen ihre freiheit
verteidigen und die verteidigen am ende
natürlich auch unsere freiheit und es
gibt ein völkerrechtlich verbrecher auf
selbstverteidigung dieses recht auf
selbstverteidigung unterstützen wir mit
diesem defensiver für lieferungen mit
dem ziel und das stimmt natürlich wir
werden mit waffenlieferungen keinen
frieden schaffen aber wir werden damit
in verbindung mit den harten
wirtschaftssanktionen das ist ja auch
wichtig dass das nur in kombination
wirkt das tutti neben an den
verhandlungstisch gezwungen wird und
dass eben die verhandlungssituation für
die ukraine eine bessere ist als wenn
wir die überhaupt keine internationale
unterstützung an der stelle bekommen
hätte und die logik des krieges das will
ich auch so deutlich sagen die hat sich
putin ausgesucht und nicht die ukraine
und auch nicht die deutsche
bundesregierung
thomas wiegold es gibt jetzt
unbestätigte aktuelle meldungen dass es
möglicherweise morgen ab 10 uhr in mario
pohl eine feuerpause geben soll wir
wissen nicht ob das glas ist oder ob es
tatsächlich der versuch ist in dieser
humanitären katastrophen zone wieder
etwas luft zu verschaffen um die
menschen möglicherweise dazu evakuieren
das bringt uns ja zu dem thema
verhandlungen halten sie verhandlungen
im moment zwischen der ukraine und
russland auf der einen seite was
waffenstillstand angeht aber vor allen
dingen auch größere verhandlungen um
einen frieden für die ukraine zu
schaffen mit sicherheitsgarantien im
moment überhaupt für realistisch
aber ich bin im moment sehr skeptisch
einfach aus dem grund weil ich bei
russland nach wie vor noch nicht sehe
dass die wirklich zu
zugeständnissen also verhandlungen
bedeutet ja auch zugeständnisse und ist
russland weiter als zu sagen geführt und
kapitulationsverhandlungen also wir
diktieren die bedingungen unter denen
die ukraine jetzt aufgibt und wir
erklären diesen waffengang für beendet
und das sehe ich im moment nicht was sie
gesagt haben mario pohl humanitäre
korridore
das hat es ja an verschiedenen stellen
immer wieder gegeben und es hat immer
wieder meldungen gegeben diese korridore
wurden dann gezielt beschossen
existiert gut die russische seite sagt
das waren die ukraine die ukraine sagen
das waren die russen wir wissen das so
nicht
allerdings wenn ich sehe die rhetorik
die russland auch gegenüber den
vereinten nationen auch gegenüber dem
internationalen komitee vom roten kreuz
führt dann habe ich nicht den eindruck
das von russischer seite solche angebote
ernst gemeint sind da ist unabhängig
davon was man wirklich an gesicherten
informationen hat diese sehr
grundsätzliche ablehnung von
internationaler vermittlung von
internationalen organisationen
das ist für mich ein zeichen dass man
sagt wir diktieren die bedingungen und
keiner sonst verhandlungen halten sie
die für realistisch und russland in
absehbarer zeit war es auf jeden fall zu
verhandeln ist dass das internationale
rote kreuz zugang bekommt und der welt
flüchtlingsrat da sperrt sich russland
bisher und ich hoffe dass von den
verhandlungen die erstaunlicherweise
eine koalition von israel und türkei
macht das die akzeptiert wird bei putin
und dass wir müssen auf verhandlungen
setzen und ich hoffe dass diese beiden
länder die akzeptanz haben was wir
verhindern sollten ist dass china die
verhandlungen diktiert weil das nicht zu
europäischen gunsten ausgeht wir haben
nur noch zwei minuten zeit frau schwamm
sie fordern jetzt eine gesellschaftliche
debatte über die frage wie wir jetzt mit
dieser bedrohung militärisch auch
umgehen könnten sie sich denn auch einer
stärkung der bundeswehr nähern wenn
gleichzeitig die regierung versichert
würde dass sie die sozialen
verpflichtungen und die zum klimaschutz
nicht fahren lässt
da würde ich eher wirklich weise sehen
wollen harte fakten bevor ich da
irgendwie mich darauf einlassen würde
und so lange die schuldenbremse in der
form auch weiter erhalten bleiben
sondern das bekenntnis zur
schuldenbremse gibt ist dafür ist dass
ein unseriöser vorschlag den sie da
machen auch schäfer im zusammenhang mit
der oper mit dem ukraine krieg geht es
ja auch immer um energielieferungen wir
sind ja erpressbar das haben wir jetzt
gesehen selbst wenn sich die situation
offensichtlich etwas entspannt hat die
gaslieferungen kommen ja noch weiter wie
sollten wir denn eigentlich damit
umgehen es gibt auch immer wieder den
forderungen auch von nato partnern
dreht den russen von westlicher seite
die gashahn ab
ja ich meine wir müssen jetzt natürlich
ganz ganz viel in kurzer zeit schaffen
was wir in den letzten jahren
verschlafen haben nämlich die
vollständige unabhängigkeit von
russischen fossilen energieträgern unser
wirtschafts und klimaminister robert
habeck versuchte jetzt diese
abhängigkeit zu beenden in einer sehr
kurzen zeit unser ziel ist natürlich ein
schrittweises in barkow mit dem ziel
einer vollständigen unabhängigkeit und
zwar so schnell wie möglich
gut dieses thema werden für vertiefen
aber nicht hier in der sendung sondern
sondern circa 24 stunden bei der oder in
der nächsten phoenix-runde ich bedanke
mich bei peter schäfer bei roderich
kiesewetter bei julia schramm und bei
thomas wiegold liebe zuschauer ich habe
angekündigt dieses thema am morgen in
der phoenix runde hpx früh waren stufe
im moment hat sich die situation am
möglicherweise etwas entspannt also
vielleicht eine leichte entwarnung aber
man weiß ja nie bei putin und deswegen
werden wir uns morgen mit diesem thema
sicherheit der energieversorgung
abhängigkeit von russland beschäftigen
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit michael
kohns darin die pressekonferenz die
robert habeck heute gehalten hat zu
dieser früh waren stufe die ja
ausgerufen hat möglicherweise muss keine
neue stufe mehr ausgerufen werden wenn
man sich betrugs dann doch einig dass
wir in zukunft unser gas mit euro oder
mit dollar bezahlen werden auf jeden
fall ein interessantes thema es gibt
auch neuigkeiten wie gesagt aus der
ukraine bleiben sie also bei uns
[Musik]